[موسيقى]
بعد انتهاء زلزال كهرمان مارش يوم السادس
من فبراير شباط وحتى الوقت الحالي لم
تتوقف الهزاف والخداديه في معظم المناطق
التي ضربها سواء في تركيا او في سوريا
استنادا لاداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
فان اكثر من 2000 هزه ارتداديه سجلت من
وقع زلزال فما هي هذه الاجزات الارتداديه
وما سببها وما مدى خطورتها يطلق على
الهزات الارتداديه توابع الزلزال او
الزلازل الصغيره اللاحقه وهي تحدث وفق
التفسير علماء من هيئه المسح الجيولوجيه
الامريكيه نتيجه محاوله الصفائح التكتونيه
للارض العوده الى مكانها على طول خط الصدع
بعد حدوث الزلزال الاشد هذه الهزات
الارتداديه او توابع الزلزال قد تستمر
اياما واسابيع وحتى سنوات من تاريخ حدوث
الزلزال الاول للاشد وفق العلماء فان شده
تلك الهزات تتفاوت مع مرور الوقت فتكون
قويه خلال 48 ساعه الاولى بعد الزلزال
الاول لكنها تحدث دائما بدرجات اقل منه ثم
انخفاض شدتها بدرجات متفاوته لكن هل يعني
انخفاض وقله درجه الهزات الارتداديه ان
الخطر قد سهل وفق تحذير كثير من هيئات
المسح الجيولوجيه في العالم فان خطوره هذه
الهزات الارتداديه تكمن في انها قد تسبب
انهيار ما خلخله وصدعه زلزال الاول من
مباني صمدت ولم تنهر كليا لذا يجب وفق
العلماء عدم المغامره بالرجوع الى اي مبنى
الا بعد تقييم حالته من المختصين